bah oui c'est c'est ça va pas avec le
business pour avoir du business il faut
du calme il faut que les clients
puissent être rassurés venir
tranquillement enfin voilà on n'est pas
alors même s'ils mettent en coupe réglé
les quartiers c'est pas des
pacificateurs et des et des gentilles
garçons mais en tout cas ils ont tout
intérêt à ce que ça se passe bien et
qu'on puisse contrôler les entrées les
sorties en tout cas voilà qui est pas de
qui est le moins possible de présence
policière c'est assez c'est du business
donc si vous voulez c'est comme comme un
grand magasin quand il y a des
manifestations ça l'arrange pas on peut
pas pénétrer chez lui bah c'est la même
chose parce que quand les commerces sont
vandalisés sont pillés ça n'a pas un
impact direct sur sur leur business ah
non c'est quand ça se passe chez eux
c'est-à-dire que c'est si vous commencez
à faire des émeutes que vous caillasser
dans le quartier et que ça fait venir la
police et bah là évidemment votre
quartier les sinistré et votre et votre
supermarché à ciel ouvert va s'arrêter
tout seul donc non ils vont pas
intervenir pour vous empêcher d'aller
casser le magasin d'électroménager à
côté de chez vous ça il s'en fiche ils
sont pas vigilent de supermarché en
revanche leur supermarché à eux oui ils
le surveille donc finalement si je
comprends bien c'est des hors la loi qui
veulent au secours de l'État ça c'est un
phénomène qui est qui est assez récent
ou quelque chose qui vole au secours de
leur propre intérêt de leur propre
intérêt mais quelque part quelque part
de l'état de service finalement à l'état
et aux habitants oui oui puisque c'est
une forme d'ordre parallèle oui et ça
c'est quelque chose qui est nouveau qui
existait déjà auparavant dans ça existe
parce qu'en 2005 quand il y a eu les
plus les grandes émeutes contre qui a
connu la France à cette époque là il y a
beaucoup de quartiers il y avait pas
bougé notamment à Marseille alors on
avait dit à Marseille que par exemple
évidemment le trafic prenait le pas sur
la révolte sociale ou anti policière
voilà donc c'est c'est des phénomènes
qui sont déjà depuis que le business est
un peu industrialisé que c'est devenu
une vraie économie parallèle on a vu
surgir ce phénomène voilà alors les
dealers ils sont plus ou moins puissants
donc ils arrivent ou pas à endiguer la
masse des émeutiers et des fauteurs de
troupes qui sont souvent les petits
mineurs incontrôlables donc soit ils ont
une autorité suffisante et une équipe
suffisante soit ils sont débordés dans
certains cas ça arrive des pertes pour
eux qu'est-ce que ça veut dire ça
chiffre en euros dizaines de milliers
d'euros par jour pour les gros point de
villes oui on peut monter à 30 000 à par
jour alors c'est du chiffre d'affaires
on est dans du commerce donc c'est du
chiffre d'affaires c'est pas la marge
net du commerçant mais en tout cas oui
la marge elle est de plusieurs milliers
voire de dizaines de milliers d'euros
pour les plus gros supermarchés mais
est-ce que ces émeutes c'est pas aussi
un moyen de tenir la police à l'écart de
montrer que finalement c'est nous qui
tenons les quartiers bah là on
s'aperçoit que moi que des émeutes on a
plutôt eu des pillages dans les
quartiers commerçants et pas forcément
ce qu'ils habitaient là on a un peu
changé au début ils ont brûlé des
voitures en bas de chez eux puis après
ils ont été rapidement qu'il y ait des
commerces donc
mais quand on va viser les les véhicules
par exemple de force de l'ordre avec des
avec des cocktails Molotov avec ce genre
de choses on montre aussi qu'on est un
peu chez nous non c'est pas forcément
lié ça pourrait ressembler une espèce de
territoire enfin voilà de défense du
territoire de dire ici ça va être une
zone de noix mais non on s'aperçoit
quand on discute avec les gros
trafiquants
tirer sur la police envoyer des des
caillassées une voiture de la BAC qui
passe ça n'a pas plus d'intérêt que de
ramener l'attention sur le quartier
ramener l'attention policière etc ou des
pouvoirs publics donc ça n'a pas grand
intérêt pour eux ça n'a pas grand
intérêt il peut y avoir des cas
résiduels où on va empêcher la police de
venir comme ça mais finalement quand
c'est bien fait le trafic de stupe entre
guillemets je veux pas toujours et bah
les dispositifs de sécurité sont faits
pour marcher et endiguer l'arrivée de la
police bien avant qu'elle ne soit là
alors il y a un autre son cloche on a
entendu notamment Christophe by je suis
le ministre de la transition écologique
lui il préfère voir dans ce début
d'apaisement de ces derniers jours le
fruit du travail de l'État et des forces
de l'ordre alors en quelques chiffres
40000 policiers gendarmes mobilisés dans
toute la France depuis depuis une
semaine depuis le début de ses émeutes
depuis plutôt une dizaine de jours
3625 personnes passées en garde à vue en
une semaine donc plus de 1100 mineurs
s'en va y revenir d'ailleurs
si les trafiquants de drogue ont joué un
rôle dans la déesse calade les forces de
l'ordre n'y sont pas pour rien non plus
oui c'est ce que je veux c'est qu'il y a
pas une raison une seule raison
là-dedans c'est un je pense une
lassitude des émeutiers en eux-mêmes on
peut ou des pilleurs on les a pris comme
vous voulez l'action de la défense de
l'ordre dans certains quartiers sans
doute que le trafic a repris le dessus
sur le désordre voilà je pense que c'est
une conjonction de facteurs il y a
jamais une seule solution et pourquoi
certains quartiers se sont embrasés et
d'autres pas du tout est-ce que là aussi
justement c'est le signe que les
narcotrafiquants continuent de faire la
loi oui bah non ce qu'on disait quand on
a regardé les émeutes de 2005 c'est ce
qu'on a à peu près constaté il y en a où
ça même pas démarré parce qu'il y a des
gens qui ont eu assez de poids alors il
y a des fois c'est pas forcément que des
dealers ça peut être des grands frères
des types quoi un peu d'autorité et qui
vont essayer de calmer la jeunesse parce
que tout le monde n'a pas intérêt à ce
que tout le monde aille tout cassé voilà
mais effectivement il y a des des des
des quartiers qui ont été épargnés mais
je vous dis c'est difficilement
quantifiable c'est au coup à coup alors
les situations
individuel mais oui on peut trouver en
tout cas il y a une logique commerciale
à ça difficilement quantitiables il y en
a en tout cas qui s'est tenté qui s'y
est tenté de manière de manière assez
franche c'est Geoffroy rugbyieux le
l'ancien patron du Medef le patron du
Medef pour encore quelques jours lui il
dit sur France Inter le premier
employeur de Seine-Saint-Denis c'est le
trafic de drogue de réduire un petit peu
oui
heureusement qu'elle tient autrement que
sur le trafic de base de haschich même
si ça représente un grand pan de
l'économie mais en France en général
aujourd'hui hein je veux dire Geoffre
Béziers il peut aller dans d'autres
départements même à la campagne même à
Villerupt on se tire dessus avec
kalistikov à la frontière du Luxembourg
on est pas en Seine-Saint-Denis et
pourtant du trafic de stup donc
aujourd'hui c'est un peu réducteur de
dire ça le trafic de stup
malheureusement il a gangrené à peu près
l'ensemble du territoire et en
Seine-Saint-Denis heureusement il y a
quand même beaucoup de gens honnêtes qui
travaillent on va pas non plus enfin
voilà c'est plusieurs millions de
personnes donc ça sera inquiétant si on
avait plusieurs millions de dealers
c'est ça qui a changé ces dernières
années c'est le fait que ce trafic de
stupéfiant il se contente plus il se
cantonne plus uniquement
uniquement au banlieue aussi t'es la SMR
en flocon de flocons de neige si on veut
dire au début ça touchait des grands des
grands centres urbains classiquement
pareil Lyon Marseille etc qui représente
des hommes commerciaux on est dans du
commerce donc il faut qu'il y a un
bassin de clientèle suffisant donc à
l'origine évidemment les grandes villes
qu'on s'entraînent les consommateurs et
donc les gros dealers et puis ce dont on
s'est aperçu en une vingtaine d'années
c'est qu'on a vu voilà ce trafic
gangrené au fur et à mesure les moyennes
villes les petites villes partout où il
y a un bassin commercial c'est un peu le
principe de la grande distribution où on
va commencer par des grands mots les
grands des grands centres que des hypers
à la campagne et puis vous allez rentrer
jusque même au cœur des villes ou des
petits villages avec des hypers adaptés
bon là c'est là c'est la même chose
c'est la même logique que le commerce
donc les gens au bout de au lieu de
d'avoir à se déplacer pour venir dans
une grande ville et faire 50 km pour
aller pécho comme on dit de la drogue et
ben ils vont trouver un dealer qui lui à
10 km grossiste un semi grossiste un
détail vous voyez c'est c'est ce
principe là alors les gens se mettent
pas dans des villages pour rien c'est à
dire ou dans des villes qui se mettent
sur des axes routiers sur des des points
stratégiques commerciaux là où il y a du
passage voilà etc donc est-ce qu'on est
une idée du nombre de personnes en
France et notamment dans les banlieues
qui vivent de ce trafic de drogue non
c'est difficilement quantifiable et
d'autant plus que vivre ça veut tout et
rien dire parce que ça reste du
capitaliste certes sauvage mais du
capitalisme donc il y a quand même une
concentration des richesses en haut de
la pyramide donc en fait les trois
quarts des gens qui travaillent dans ce
trafic qui travaillent entre guillemets
sont des smicards voilà des gens qui
vont toucher 50 100 euros jour hier plus
il y a beaucoup hein mais voilà mais le
gros des millions va quand même aller en
haut de la pyramide c'est pas une ONG
c'est pas associatif c'est pas des gens
qui redistribuent leur argent gentiment
voilà c'est pas du tout un système
communiste donc oui il y a beaucoup de
gens qui en vivent mais il y a beaucoup
de gens qui ont eu petitement chichement
de quoi faire les courses de quoi
acheter un sandwich au gamin de quoi se
payer ses cigarettes de quoi aller à
dans un parc d'attraction le week-end ça
c'est la majorité bien pour ça que les
gens qui sont dans ce trafic ils ont
entre 16 et 20 ans ce qu'on voit sur le
terrain comme on dit sur les terrains
l'équipe qui a 25 ans il a d'autres
ambitions que de gagner 50 euros par
jour assis sur une chaise donc on a
évidemment l'excuse de minorité qui leur
sert pour voilà échapper à la police
mais c'est aussi parce que les sommes
sont pas dingues donc elles vont bien
pour un type qui a 16 17 18 ans au-delà
ça va pas suffire donc voilà donc oui ça
fait des gens alors le petit gars il va
remonter chez lui il va irriguer
peut-être un peu la famille qui va sa
mère va aller faire des courses avec ses
100 euros etc mais je veux dire voilà
ils vont pas s'acheter une Mercedes ils
vont pas avoir des loft sur la Côte
d'Azur oui ceux qui sont à la tête où
ils ont même beaucoup plus ils ont des
demi-tour à Dubaï même et ceux qui sont
à la tête justement quels sont leurs
méthodes on s'installe dans un point de
Deal et ensuite c'est la loi du plus
fort oui bah c'est ça alors avant on
s'installer chez soi dans son point de
deal en bas de chez soi parce qu'on
contrôlé l'environnement puis on traduit
que ses copains puis au bout d'un moment
la logique et commerciale on s'aperçoit
que le point de l'île des autres il
marche mieux parce qu'il est mieux placé
il a la sortie de l'autoroute et au
croisement de deux grands axes routiers
etc donc et bon au bout d'un moment on
va se dire
et là il y a pas d'autres moyens de
réguler ce commerce que par la force on
va pas aller au tribunal de commerce ou
essayer de faire une OPA sauvage oui
l'opéra sauvage vous explique ça
s'appelle une cariechnikov on met de la
762 il y en a 30 et on tire sur le sur
les concurrents ou en tout cas sur les
compétiteurs et donc voilà donc ça se
règle comme ça effectivement donc avant
chacun travaillait dans son coin et se
contentait en gros de ce qu'il avait
c'était un peu la loterie du dealer bah
je suis né dans un endroit qui est mal
placé j'ai un petit business et puis
aujourd'hui et ben on passe on passe à
la concurrence féroce enfin voilà donc
vous allez de guerre vous avez parlé des
jeunes vous en avez rencontré un certain
nombre dans le cadre de vos activités de
vos documentaires qui sont ces jeunes
comment est-ce qu'ils arrivent dans ces
réseaux là comment est-ce qu'on est
recruté bon alors le le le je vous dis
ceux qui sont tout en bas le pire c'est
que c'est même pas des voyous ce jeu
durablement du gamin des gamins pas
forcément d'ailleurs du quartier parce
que on va pas rentrer dans les tailles
techniques mais ils embauchent rarement
les gens de chez eux pour éviter qu'ils
soient connus les font tourner pour que
les têtes alors comment est-ce qu'il se
retrouve donc en fait c'est du bouche à
oreille alors maintenant vous avez même
des annonces sur les réseaux sociaux on
dit le réseau de machins à Toulouse
recrute quatre vendeurs de guetteurs
donc vous avez un espèce de Pôle Emploi
parallèle et sinon c'est du bouche à
oreille donc ça va être on va faire
tourner le mot dans un quartier il y en
a un qui est déjà guetteur dans une cité
il rentre chez lui puis il va dire aux
copains bah tiens-moi je travaille pour
un réseau qui est dans la ville d'à côté
ou à 2 km il cherche deux autres gars
ils ont des casiers verts tous ces
petits dessus on gravit des échelons oui
mais les trois quarts ils vont jamais
les gravir les échelons ils vont prendre
un petit boulot ils vont le faire
jusqu'à ce qu'ils aient droit c'est
horrible de dire ça au minima sociaux
pour ceux qui vont pas forcément aller
bosser etc et ils vont quitter le voilà
ils vont quitter le trafic parce que
vraiment libre d'en sortir oui on est
libre après si vous êtes à un poste un
peu clé c'est compliqué mais tous ces
gamins là cette cloisonné il faut pas
imaginer qu'ils savent même pour qu'ils
vende ils savent même pas pour qu'ils
vendent la tête de réseau pensez bien
contre le gars qui fait la surveillance
assise sur une chaise qui a 15 ans et le
big boss qui fait venir 400 kg de
haschich à vendre dans le quartier ou
dans les cités alentours personne ne le
connaît il y a que ce qu'on appelle il
fallait mettre des circuit des fusibles
donc en fait ces gamins-là ils ont même
pas un profil de délinquant généralement
tout ce qu'on leur dit c'est tu t'assois
sur une chaise tu vois une voiture de
police tu te mets hurler et puis tu
gagnes 50 euros ils en sont guère plus
ceux qui vont faire carrière c'est 1% de
pour cent trois pour cent le problème
c'est qu'il y a un réservoir en bas de
l'échelle qui est quasiment infini
c'est-à-dire ses gamins de cayans c'est
le 15 saisons qui réalise pas vraiment
la gravité du truc parce que c'est 50
balles gagné rapidement en bas de
l'immeuble voilà sauf que là quand même
ça commence à changer notamment à
Marseille ou les politiques
d'intimidation et de terreur des dealers
qui s'entretuent entre quartiers entre
cités fait que maintenant ça devient les
premières victimes de ce de ces guerres
des stups donc là où c'était un petit
job tranquille à 50 euros aujourd'hui ça
vous faites tuer pour 50 euros donc là
ça commence à être un peu plus court
mais justement le recrutement commence
c'est une chose de faire du trafic de
drogue c'en est une autre de tirer à
l'arme de guerre comment est-ce qu'il se
retrouve certains d'entre eux avec des
kalachnikov parfois des bazooka des
grenades alors les armes de guerre elles
viennent on le sait classiquement des
pays en guerre donc nous on a ramassé à
la suite des années 90 et des conflits
en exogoslavie bah tout l'armement donc
en gros des armes d'Europe de l'Est des
ch'tit Coffe etc du centex des explosifs
à peu près où il y avait même les vidéos
des RPG7 c'est ce qu'on appelle
vulgairement à lance-roquette ou un
bazooka ces armes là elles sont arrivées
au compte-goutte à la fin des années 90
on les a vu surgir à partir de 96 97 sur
des attaques de fourgon blindés ce genre
de choses les dealers en HTM et s'en
servaient pas à l'époque en gros ils
allaient beau hein comme De Niro dans
Taxi Driver devant sa glace de salle de
bain et puis un jour voilà et puis un
jour en 2016
on va commencer à les hostilités ça va
devenir assez assez ardu et en 2005-2006
voilà il y a un téméraire qui a commencé
à sortir le truc et puis on a vu parmi
métisse par imitation et le problème
c'est qu'aujourd'hui si vous sortez plus
la cage du coffre ou autre arme de
guerre en cas de conflit vous on vous
prend plus au sérieux le problème c'est
que c'est un business où ça marche pas
au CV ça marche à la réputation si une
fois donc il y a une escalade de la
violence enfin voilà bon c'est ça tout
ça pour expliquer donc ces arbres voilà
elles viennent des pays en guerre elles
viennent des collectionneurs qui
remisent des armes qu'on peut acheter
légalement des militarisés et puis il y
a le milieu pour eux entre le milieu
criminel et les collectionneurs enfin
voilà il y a toute une nébuleuse comme
ça mais c'est du trafic de fourmi il
faut pas imaginer des containers qui
arrivent avec 2000 kalachnikov dans le
port de Marseille c'est bon c'est du
trafic de fourmis il y a pas que des
armes il y a par exemple des voitures de
sport en l'occurrence la voiture de du
jeune du jeune Naël elle était
immatriculée en Pologne une grosse
voiture de sport à la chasse c'est
minimum 50000 euros comment comment le
système il est assez classique
effectivement on a vu ça arriver alors
avant il y avait donc c'est un peu le
sport national dans les quartiers on
aime rouler avec des grosses berlines
allemandes généralement sportif qu'on
peut pas forcément se payer donc on les
loue donc il y a eu des des loueurs et
là la voiture en l'occurrence elle vient
de Pologne pense que depuis quelques
années c'est la mode parce que la
législation polonaise permet notamment
de sous louer des voitures donc les
loueurs français de quartier qui loue
ses bagnoles de sport ces voitures de
sport assez jeune au lieu de les détenir
eux-mêmes ils vont les louer à des
loueurs des sous-doués à des loueurs
polonais et en plus comme ça en plein de
polonaise et ben évidemment les
retraites pointent toutes ces choses-là
vous allez passer à travers quand vous
en servez donc c'est à bénéfice pour
tout le monde il casse les prix les
Polonais ils ont le droit de vous le
souder et vous vous avez le droit de les
relouer à des citoyens français enfin
bon voilà c'est ça la cascade alors ça
c'est fait avant que la Roumanie ça se
fait qu'un certain nombre de pays de
l'Est et aujourd'hui c'est la Pologne
qui prédomine donc on voit un certain
nombre est fin de voiture en plein
polonaise qui valent plusieurs dizaines
voire centaines de milliers d'euros
merci beaucoup Jérôme c'est moi qui vous
remercie journaliste et réalisateur
spécialiste du grand banditisme merci
beaucoup d'être venu dans point de vue
aujourd'hui